[Musique]
Costa Gavras, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons encore sur une chaîne
YouTube qui s'appelle Syerview, une
chaîne internet qui diffuse en direct.
On a eu un petit souci de son, donc on
est revenu. Euh, est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement s'il vous
plaît ?
Je m'appelle Costa Gavras, je suis mteur
en scène. J'ai vu en France, je suis je
suis citoyen français, je vis en France
depuis 60 ans. J'ai fait des études à la
SB et puis à l'école du cinéma. Et
après, j'étais assistant metteur en
scène quelques célèbres
metteurs en scène René Clair, René
Clément, Jacques Demi, Gionon et
quelques autres Verneœil. Et après j'ai
fait mon premier film qui s'appelait
compartimentaire et j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir des acteurs extraordinaires que
mon temps signorait trintigant beaucoup
grâce au qui je faire mon film et depuis
je continue
Palme d'or Oscar
le le prix à Berlin et cetera et cetera
quoi. Enfin bon
là vous avez fait un vous avez fait
plusieurs films. votre dernier film en
2012 et votre dernier film en 2019, ça
parle d'argent, de grand capital, ça
parle de finances internationales, ça
parle de d'institutions européennes.
Pourquoi vous avez décidé de de faire ce
ce film alors que le sujet est aride,
personne s'y intéresse,
c'est pas bandant comme je vous ai dit
précédemment. Pourquoi faire ça ?
parce que j'étais interpellé par la
Grèce, par la crise qui a éclaté en
Grèce il y a une dizaine d'années et ça
m'a interpellé. Je j'ai été interpellé
une première fois en agresse et c'était
quand la les militaires ont pris les
pouvoirs et j'ai eu la chance à l'époque
aussi d'avoir un bon livre entre les
mains. J'ai fait un film qui s'appelait
Z. Cette fois-ci c'était de nouveau
interpellé par la Grèce. C'est le drame
que vivaient les Grecs.
Alors, je suis allé voir sur place, j'ai
vu ce qui s'est passé et très vite j'ai
pensé faut faire un film, faut faire une
sorte une sorte de mélodrame sur la vie
quotidienne des Grecs qui
leur ils ont vu leur salaire baisser de
40 %. Ils ont vu les chômages montés à
des autosu extraordinaires près de 40 de
30 %.
les les dettes aussi, il y avait une
dette colossale qui s qui était d au
gouvernement qui ont procéder la crise
qui ont laissé la dette monter
énormément l'
supportation de vote.
Absolument. Oui. Dette que le peuple ne
pouvit absolument pas payer. Alors les
banques sont intervenues et ils ont dit
il faut la payer quand même et c'était
donc tout ça m'a intéressé énormément.
J'ai voulu faire un film et très vite,
je me suis aperçu que dans cette
histoire-elà, il y avait un autre
personnage qui était l'Europe. L'Europe,
c'est banque et et et l'Union
européenne. Et comme l'Europe
m'intéressait beaucoup, j'ai dis voilà,
je vais faire pas un mélodrame, je fais
une tragédie parce que les Grecs
vivaient une tragédie et avec les
données d'une tragédie. Et la donnée
tragédie c'était quoi ? C'était tout le
monde à cette aventure a raison mais
c'est pas la raison de tout le monde et
c'est pas la raison surtout du peuple
grec qui souffrait. Donc j'ai commencé à
réunion du matériel pendant des mois et
des années mais j'ai trouvé pas le fond
de l'histoire. J'ai trouvé pas à
l'intérie ce qui s'est passé à
l'intérieur de l'Europe. J'avais tout ce
qui s'est passé à l'extérieur et rien à
l'intérieur. Jusqu'au jour où le
ministre grec Vaoufis de gauche a
commencé à négocier la dette.
Et
très vite, il y a eu référendum pour
voir s'il fallait suivre ou accepter le
dictat européen ou pas. Et c'est ces
référendum a été voté à 61 % des
personnes en Grèce. Et je me suis dit il
va se passer quelque chose. Et ben il y
a rien il s'est rien passé. Les
Européens n'ont pas changé d'avis et le
gouvernement de Cypras a accepté le le
référendum accepté le dictat. Il a voté
le dictat et vaoufakis a démissionné le
ministre de la finance. Alors je me suis
dit je vais voir cet homme. Qu'est-ce
qui se passe ? J'étais le voir, il m'a
expliqué comment ça se passait les
réunions à l'intérieur de de
l'eurogroupe, à l'intérieur des ces
instances européennes
qu' a qu'il a enregistré d'une façon euh
cachée.
Ah oui, en plus il s'est aperçu très
vite qu'il y avait pas de contre-indus
pendant ces réunions. Alors qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait ? il a enregistré tout cela
et c'est ça qui était intéressant et
fondamental pour le film c'estàd que
j'avais la solution du scénario pour ce
qui s'est passé se disait et se passé à
l'intérêt de ces réunions et c'est comme
là je lui demandé de collaborer avec
lui. Il m'a dit "Non, j'écris un livre."
Je vais lire le livre. Et il a commencé
à m'envoyer les chapitres les uns après
les autres. Et voilà, j'ai pu trouver
tout ce qu'il fallait pour finir le
scénario et j'ai fait le film.
Vous avez été sur le terrain pour
enquêter sur la vie des Grecs ? Vous
avez
Non, j'ai pas voulu voir les Oui, parce
que je voulais le faire au début comme
je vous ai dit fin des gram mélodan
montrer que les Grecs d'abord il y avait
des suicides un peu partout. D'abord, il
y avait plusieurs
les étudiantes
les suicides ont monté à 45 % très vite
de la prostitution chez les étudiantes
partout il fallait survivre donc tout
est possible la prostitution chez les
garçons chez les filles les touristes
arrivaient massivement donc c'est très
facile d'avoir de la clientèle mais je
n'insistais veux pas insister sur ce qui
m'intéressait surtout sur le fait que la
vie commençait à se défaire peu à peu
comme un tissu qui qui pourra pour
pourrit les jeunes qui n'avaient pas de
travail partaient à l'étranger il est
parti sans 500000 peut-être même 600000
dit aujourd'hui. Alors avec leur
savoir-faire ne servirait plus à la
Grèce, servirait à l'étranger à d'autres
pays pour lesquels c'était pas fait. Les
familles ont changé complètement style.
Les jeunes qui étaient mariés, ils
avaient un ou deux enfants, il avait
plus de travail, il revenait chez papa
et maman et tous viv ensemble. C'était
vraiment insupportable. Mais je voulais
pas entrer à ça. Je voulais montrer une
tragédie voir qui est le responsable et
les résultats qui arrivent chez les
Grecs. Voilà. essentiellement le le but
que j'ai voulu suivre et c'est comme ça
que j'ai fait les scénarios et par la
suite les films pour montrer vraiment le
rôle essentiel de l'Europe dans tout
cela et aussi le cynisme de l'Europe et
j'ai utilisé beaucoup ce cynisme dans la
construction du scénario parce que je
pense que le cynisme a quelque chose de
de suspense. Les relations cyniques
entre les gens créent un spectacle
vraiment qu'on a pas l'habitude de voir.
Et je crois que c'est ce qui est arrivé
avec le film. Vous les avez rencontrés
les gens de l'Europe entre guillemets,
ces gens qui prenaient les décisions ou
vous vous avez juste une perception à
travers les mots et les lettres de
Varoufakis ? Non, j'ai vu une préception
à travers le livre de Franquis parce que
j'écoutais ce qu'ils avaient dit que si
j'allais le demander les demander aux
uns aux autres, ils allaient me raconter
l'histoire et vous savez les hommes
politiques racontent toujours l'histoire
voilà qui est qu' est grandi qui les
rend le meilleur du monde et cetera et
je voulais j'ai ouis un témoignage
précis et c'était le témo les
enregistrements des fquis et il note
aussi parce qu'il avait pris beaucoup
beaucoup de notes. Dans une des notes
par exemple, j'ai découvert que il a dit
il avait la date et le premier ministre
m'a dit aujourd'hui qu' se sentait comme
un espadon pris à l'amçon. Un premier
ministre qui se sent comme un espadon
pris à l'hameçon. L'ameçon lequel ?
L'hameçon européen. C'est il pouvait
rien faire, ils avaient paralysé
complètement. sont allemands.
Voilà, les Allemands bien sûr parce que
l'Europe était et si on continue comme
ça, elle va l'être encore pilotée
complètement par les Allemands qui
s'intéressent à mon avis
à eux-mêmes, aux intérêts national
allemandes mais pas aux intérêts de
l'Europe.
Est-ce que vous êtes renseigné un petit
peu sur pourquoi la Grèce est rentrée
dans l'Europe ? Ah mais ça c'est le
grand problème et j'ai je suis convaincu
d'une chose. L'Europe a fait une autre
grande faute, c'est de entrer faire
entrer les la Grèce immédiatement à
l'Europe.
C'était une faute, c'était une faute qui
était voulue.
Non. Oui, c'était voulu mais il fallait
d'abord Mais il connaissait les
Européens connaissaient très très bien
que ça marchait pas très bien en Grèce.
Il y a pas des grandes banques qui ont
trafiqué le bilan de la Grèce pour
pouvoir lui permettre de rentrer dans
dans l'Europe.
Non mais il y avait une une une
corruption énorme à la Grèce. Il y avait
une manque de gouvernance sérieuse et
les Européens le savaient. Certains en
profitaient d'ailleurs. Ils arrivaient
jusqu'à à à payer à donner des
bacchiches à à des ministres pour faire
des affaires. Il y a des ministres qui
ont été en prison aussi par la suite
parce qu'on a découvert qu'il a touché 5
millions d'euros. Vous rendez compte ?
Donc les les Européens avaient une sorte
de mépris, je dirais pour pour la Grèce
et il ne devrai pas normalement la faire
entrer à l'Europe. Il devrait dire voilà
vous entre vous voulez entrer en Europe,
vous allez pendant 4 5 ans changer tout,
votre gouvernance, la façon de payer
payer des impôts, faire un cadastre
parce qu'il y a pas de cadastre, tous
ces changements et quand vous vous les
aurez fait et ben on vous rentrera en
l'Europe. Vous êtes pas du tout au
courant du fait qu'il y a des grandes
banques qui aidaient euh la Grèce à
présenter ses comptes d'une façon très
rose avec des lunettes roses. Vous êtes
pas les gens banques n'aident pas. Elles
font des affaires et tirent des affaires
pour leur actionnaires.
L'Allemagne avait peut-être besoin d'un
euro moins fort et donc la Grèce diluait
la valeur de l'euro.
Oui. Oui. Mais ça c'est c'est parce
qu'ils l'ont fait entrer. Ils l'ont fait
entrer et le Gabji a continué. Donc il
fallait pas la faire rentrer, lui
imposer des changements radicaux de
gouvernance et après la faire rentrer.
Mais le président Jandestin à l'époque,
il avait dit "On peut pas laisser en
dehors de de l'Europe la la patrie de
Platon". Ils l'ont fait entrer et puis
le le foutroi a continué et c'est même
puré. Voilà.
C'est pour ça c'est pour ça que il y a
Oui, je confonds l'Europe avec l'Union
européenne, désolé.
Il me parle en même temps sur internet,
c'est pour ça. Est-ce que Est-ce que
vous avez compris quand on on a objecté
à Varoufakis le fait que la Grèce
demandait de l'aide alors que c'était un
pays qui avait utilisé 327 milliards
pour des femmes et de l'alcool ?
On l'a dit ça à un moment donné, c'est
que d'une totale mais ça fait beaucoup
d'argent quand même ça. Mais et ça c'est
ce qui est terrible, c'est un des
responsable européen qui a dit ça qui
dit qui était le président du regroupe.
Il a pu dire ça économiste d'abord sur
le plan d'économie c'est pas très
sérieux. Alors sur le plan du peuple
grec, c'était quand même du racisme de
dire qu'un peuple pouit dépenser autant
d'argent pour non l'argent a été dépensé
parce que le gouvernement précédent pour
des raisons clientellistes ont laissé
les banques libres. Alors à tel point
que les banques disaient vous voulez de
l'argent pour votre pour vos vacances,
on vous en donne. Vous voulez des
vacances pour les faire des cadeaux
pendant Noël, on vous en donne. Et comme
ça la dette a monté. La dette a monté
aussi pour d'autres raisons parce que
les Européens vendaient
des produits de guerre. L'Allemagne
vendait des tanks, vendait les
sous-marins, les Français vend des
hélicopt absolument vend des
hélicoptères à crédit. Et c'est comme ça
que peu parce que ça les arrangeait, ça
faisait marcher les usines et puis les
les la dette est monté à tel point et
puis entre-temps une énorme crise
américaine, la Loman Brothers Bank a
fait faillite et ils ont vu la dette
Grec et Norm, ils sont dit voilà ça va
s'arriver des catastrophes chez nous
aussi parce que donc pour sauver leur
banque on demander à au Grecs les payer
ces 360
millions puisque aujourd'hui c'est
milliard
pardon milliard oui absolument milliards
oui on s'en rend pas compte d'ailleurs
Donc million milliard, c'est une
abstraction totale.
Vous avez compris dans dans les
entretiens cachés de les enregistrements
cachés de Varok Faakis, vous avez
compris en fait ce stress de de des
dirigeants de de notre Europe de cet
effet domino tant redouté, c'est-à-dire
les banques grecques faisaient tomber
les banques françaises, les banques
françaises faisaient tomber d'autres
banques et c'est peut-être pour ça
qu'ils ont saigné à blanc le peuple grec
pour éviter ce ce cet effet domino. La
crise oui oui la crise a commencé
d'abord en Europe. Les banques
européennes avaient
un un un un trilliard trilliard c'estàd
1000 milliards de de dettes. Et puis
monsieur Sarkozy et puis les Allemands
sont trouvés devant ces problèmes.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait ? Ils ont dit
bah qui va le payer ? Le peuple. Le
peuple il a payé, il ont payé une partie
600 milliards et puis il est resté 300
milliards et puis là 400 milliards et
puis là là ils sont dit c'est la dette
grecque et ben c'est le peuple grec qui
va le payer mais le grec peuple n'avait
pas d'argent payer de cela c'est
impossible c'est un petit pays c'est une
somme absolument astronomique donc il
peut pas la payer mais alors là ils sont
intervenus il disent voilà pour la payer
il faut renvoyer beaucoup de nom il faut
monter les impôts, il faut baisser les
salaires et cetera c'est qui finalement
est une contre contradiction aussi parce
que il crée un vide économique parce que
avec la baisse des des salaires et
l'augmentation des impôts les les gens
n'avaient pas de quoi payer les d'avoir
fait des achats et il les boutiques
fermaient donc il y a des milliers des
milliers des boutiques qui ont fermé et
et pendant que les Européens disaient il
faut payer encore alors pour trouver de
l'argent qu'est-ce ils ont commencé à
tout vendre la Grèce ils disaient les
aéroports des plages et tout ce qu'il
pouvait les a des des ports tout ce
qu'il pouvait pour essayer de payer la
dette. Mais la dette était tellement
élevée et les AG étaient tellement
énormes qu'il ne payaient que les AG. Et
la dette jusqu'aujourd'hui, elle est un
peu plus forte qu'elle était à l'époque.
Quand vous parlez de racisme dans le
vocabulaire, vous parlez des pigs,
Portugal, Irlande, Grèce, Espagne
et et du fait que The Pigs don't fly.
Est-ce que dans ce vocabulaire euh
dédaigneux, insultant en face du peuple
grec, c'est ce qui a favorisé l'extrême
droite, l'ascension de l'extrême droite
dorée en Grèce ? Le fait qu'on manque de
respect aux Grecs, est-ce que les Grecs
se sont réfugiés vers l'extrême droite
parce qu'on leur manquait de respect ?
Quand la démocratie faiblit, qui gagne
c'est l'extrême droite parce que gauche
ou l'extrême gauche dans l'extrême
centre. Enfin, les extrêmes gagnent de
toute façon mais oui aussi. Oui.
L'extrême quoi
centre ?
Oui, mais là dans le cas grec ce qui ce
qui a bénéficié énormément c'est
l'extrême droite, les nazis, un parti
complètement nazi. Et alors, il est
monté à 9 % 10 % presque. Il a une
représentation à la Chambre des députés
des 30 députés. C'était c'était vraiment
profondément humiliant et on se
comprenait pas pourquoi le peuple a voté
ces gens-là. Et puis il y a les gens qui
ont voté qui ont vu qu'on a un
gouvernement de de gauche et gauche
radical, qu'est-ce qu'il faisait ? Ils
avaient peur parce que la gauche fait
toujours peur et ils votaient à droite
et le plus à droit possible. Il y a
cette espèce de Mais derrière tout cela
avait quand même l'Europe qui ne lâchait
pas un tout petit peu du l'est pour
pouvoir dire voilà on peut trouver une
solution. Il voulait pas des solutions.
Il il tellement il ne voulait pas des
solutions qu'à un moment donné Fakis, ça
a été demandé le le ministre allemand,
il lui dit vous me demandez ça des
choses infaisables. À ma place qu'est-ce
que vous feriez ? Vous savez ce que lui
a répondu le ministre allemand ?
Je ferai exactement la même chose que
vous, c'est-à-dire défendre les intérêts
de mon pays.
Voilà. Il dit moi je je signerai pas ce
j'accepterai pas. Et tout de suite
après, il aurait commencé à dire voilà
maintenant il faut payer la dette.
Voilà dans les quelles situations comico
on s'est trouvé. C'est pour ça que j'ai
voulu faire cette tragédie mais avec
maintenant de la mainant aussi de la
comédie à l'intérieur de cela et et de
l'ironie parce que tous cela c'était des
hommes sérieux, c'est des hommes graves
qui sortaient de ces réunions et
disaient voilà on fait tout pour sauver
la Grèce. Il faisait d'espèces de
discours murobolant et que tout le monde
croyait et parallèlement il disait
vaoufis, il comprend rien, il propose
des choses qui ne peuvent pas se faire,
il est complètement en de la plaque.
C'est quand mé un qui rêve ou qui triche
voilà et et il y avait cette relation
qui m'a intéressé énormément et c'est ça
que j'ai mis dans le film
essentiellement.
Je vais ouvrir une parenthèse. Vous avez
fait un film avec Gadel Mané qui Gadel
Malé qui s'appelle Le Capital. capital
et euh un film qui parle de l'ascension
d'un banquier landa qui devient un homme
prédateur
euh euh avec des des des conduites
irrespectueuses par rapport à à l'homme
avec un grand tâche. Est-ce que vous
êtes plus immergé dans cette déconnexion
du monde de la finance par rapport aux
intérêts du peuple ? Est-ce que vous
avez rencontré des traders, des gens
dans les salles de marché ? Est-ce que
vous avez rencontré des banquiers ?
Est-ce qu'ils vous ont parlé à bâton
rompu leur façon de percevoir le peuple
?
Non, les banquers tout ça, j'avais
rencontré des banques des grands
présidents en France.
Qui ça ? OK pour faire un pas du
important de de de de la banque euh
enfin de banque française
BNP société générale
non l'autre
CIC Crédit mutuel
la banque pâche
mais quoi qu'il en soit sans faire un
procè ils vous disent tous on fait tout
pour sauver le peuple on fait tout pour
aider la société tout notre effort c'est
pour aider la société et ça n'est pas
vrai du tout ça n'est pas vrai du tout
qu'est-ce que vous voulez lui répondre
c'est pour ça que je fais ce film avec
Gardel le malin. Pourquoi ? Parce que il
y a une banque qui a un problème et pour
gagner quelques temps, il mettent au
pouvoir un jeune homme très très
dynamique, très bien et lui donne tous
les pouvoirs en pensant qu' très peu de
temps après, ils vont les changer et bah
lui il prend les pouvoirs et ben il s'en
sert jusqu'en fond et les pouvoirs c'est
une drogue. C'est pouvoir les pouvoirs
d'argent à ce niveau-là, on peut tout
avoir commencé par les femmes jusqu'à
l'argent tout. et bien il utilise son
pouvoir et il fait ce qu'il veut. Il
s'en fiche tout du reste. Mais il reste
il reste quand même lucide.
Il reste lucide jusqu'au bout et il dit
que voilà je sais ce que j'ai fait, je
le fais quand même parce qu'il y a pas
d'autres solution.
C'est quoi la maladie du pouvoir ?
La maladie du pouvoir c'est tout c'est
le matin avant un chauffeur qui est là
l'appartement est payé. Il y a des gens
autour de vous qui sont à vos pieds et
et puis je fais ceci, je fais cela, j'ai
un avion, je vais je parle de ces
pouvoirs là hein très très élevé. J'ai
un avion, je vais à New York demain. Je
Non, mais ça c'est des pouvoirs de
petits bras ça.
Non, non, ça c'est c'est les pouvoirs
c'est les pouvoirs qu'on a sur les
autres.
Ouais mais vous me dites avion privé
avoir des domestiques. Ça c'est c'est
des c'est du pouvoir
c'est ça qui excite les gens par rapport
aux gens qui n'ont rien. C'est ça le
pouvoir.
Ça c'est du pouvoir de petit bras ça non
de
de petits bras de de de petits chèqus.
C'est des petits bras. Non non c'est qui
dirigent des grandes compagnies c'est
eux qui ont le pouvoir mais qui
dépendent tous si vous voulez des
actionnaires. D'ailleur ce qui est
formidable c'est que ils tiennent tant
qu'ils peuvent apporter aux actionnaires
ce que les actionnaires veulent. Les
jours où les actionnaires où ils ne
peuvent pas porter suffisamment aux
actionnaires, c'est-à-dire le minimum
c'est 10 %, le mieux c'est 10, 20 15 %
et cetera. Mais s'il baissent en dessous
du 10, ça arrive, on les met à la porte,
on prend quelqu'un qui fait le travail.
Il y a cette relation du avec le
pouvoir. Je vais je vais encore ouvrir
une parenthèse.
Vous connaissez très bien le milieu du
cinéma, je pense. Palme d'or, l'Oscar,
tout ça.
On va on va mélanger un peu les deux. la
maladie du pouvoir et il lit de
l'égalité. Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
l'affaire Epstein ?
Faireine, c'est pas tellement du cinéma
hein. C'est un type qui sautait des
filles, qui avait beaucoup d'argent qui
v qui avait des gens qui lui apportaient
des filles qu'il voulaient,
des filles très jeunes.
Des filles très jeunes évidemment, il
préfèrent les jeunes plutôt qu' les plus
âgées. Voilà. Mais mais ça n'a rien avec
le cinéma tout cela. Et je connais
autant que vous connaissez-vous beaucoup
de monde, je trouve ça et ce qui est
important c'est qu'on le sait
aujourd'hui parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
gens le cachaient pendant des années.
C'est genre des gens des C'est ça les
pouvoirs aussi. Monsieur Hstein, il
avait énorme de pouvoirs pour venir à
Paris avec son avion, téléphoner, dire
pour trouver moi quelques filles qui
m'attendent le soir. Voilà, c'est ça le
pouvoir. Mais enfin, mais le vrai
pouvoir ce n'est pas là quand même. Ça
c'est ça ce sont à mon avis des des des
des des des marginaux des marginaux du
pouvoir. Non, le pouvoir c'est l'autre.
C'est monsieur qui dirige Google
aujourd'hui. C'est monsieur qui gouge
qui dirige Facebook et qui dit "J'ai
fait une monnaie, fait une monnaie à
moi." C'est fait une monnaie qui
s'appelle Libra. Et alors qu'on on
pourra euh on peut voir on va pouvoir
changer des monnaies, envoyer la monnaie
voulait, recevoir quand on voulait et
cetera et touses les règles qui ont été
établi depuis des années maintenant sur
les circulation des monnaies pour éviter
les terrorolisme et pour éviter aussi le
lavage d'argent et cetera avec sa
monnaie change complètement. C'estàd il
sont arrivés ce pouvoir là est arrivé à
concurrencer la le pouvoir démocratique
et alors le pouvoir démocratique
européen qui lui aussi il s'est été
filoché le long des années parce que les
démocraties obéissent au pouvoir
allemand complètement qui ne pas changer
fait que il un affaiblissement de
l'Union européenne considérable et que
ça continue comme ça à mon avis je sais
pas comment l'Europe va pouvoir voir se
placer face à ces colosses de l'argent.
Je j'en ai cité deux mais il y en a
beaucoup d'autres et encore pire sont la
plupart d'entre elles elles sont
installées au Luxembourg où il ne payent
pas d'impôts.
C'est votre copain Jean-Claude ?
Jean-Claude Junker
le bouquin ?
Non non c'est votre copain Jean-Claude
Junker ?
Mon copain ? Non.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cet
homme-là ?
Quoi pensez ?
Il a fait son pays un paradis fiscal
extraordinaire.
Il a dirigé l'Europe.
C'est un personnage
à mon avis pour lequel je n'ai aucune
estime. C'est un personnage
ce qui est triste avec ces personnages,
c'est qu'on l'a fait président
de la Commission européenne. Ce qui est
encore plus triste, c'est que tout le
monde l'embrasse, que tout le monde l'a
décoré. Et vous allez voir demain ou
après-demain quand il fera son son
adieu, ils vont être tous là pour la
dire et cetera. Or, c'est le pire des
personnages. Il a fait perdre à l'Europe
des milliards pour gagner quelques
millions en son pays. Et vous savez
d'ailleurs que son pays, il a un niveau
de vie le plus élevé de l'Europe,
peut-être même un des plus élevés au
monde. Le le le SMIG là-bas, il est 1900
€. Voilà. Donc c'est parce que les
grosses compagnies qui sont réfugiées là
payent des impôts et ils font
ils font que le reste de l'Europe trouve
dans ces situations économiques dans
laquelle se trouve actuellement et la
démocratie est pire plus que tout. Avec
votre expérience
de réalisateur sur des sujets tellement
arides, est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a
une upper classe suprême, omnipotente,
omniprésente
qui s'est arrogé tous ces pouvoirs ? Le
pouvoir de la production de la monnaie,
le pouvoir de contrôler les dettes, de
faire de la surveillance. Est-ce que
vous sentez une upper class se
désolidariser
du vivre ensemble avec la pleb ?
Absolument.
Absolument. C'est-à-dire que la ce qu'on
appelle la démocratie, c'est-à-dire le
capitalisme, le libéralisme a enfanté
des monstres peu à peu parce qu'il s'est
laissé aller enfanter des monstres comme
ceux que que j'ai annoncé. Il y a un
autre Amazon par exemple, qu'est-ce
qu'il a ? Des milliers des milliers
d'ouvriers, il dit "C'est moi qui fait
la convention collective, c'est moi qui
décide ce que voilà qu'est-ce qu'on fait
nous Donc c'est ces ces ces monstres qui
ont été enfrentés, si on les dirige pas,
bah je sais pas où nous allons
Qu'est-ce qui a amené à à engendrer ces
monstreslà ? C'est le système éducatif.
On a fait un système éducatif où on ne
sélectionne que les petits requins pour
faire des des gros requins. C'est c'est
quoi ? C'est c'est le manque d'éthique,
c'est la passivité intellectuelle des
gens. C'est le rond rond quotidien qui a
permis que les plus mégalomanes
agressifs accèdent à des places de
pouvoir. C'est quoi ? Vous savez, j'ai
pas des réponses comme j'ai pas j'ai des
questions aussi un peu comme tout le
monde des questions. Comment on est pu
arriver là ? Parce que c'est vrai que on
dit on est en démocratie, on vote pour
la démocratie et parallèlement on sait
dans cette démocratie même il se font
des choses qu'on accepte pas. Mais nous
nous peuple comment on peut réagir ? Bon
je peux réagir en faisant un film très
bien vous une émission comme ça vous le
dites comme ça les gens apprennent. Mais
la grande partie du du peuple il vote
une fois de 4 ans 5 ans et et c'est la
seule voix qu'il a. Alors, comment faire
? Vous avez des aussi des hommes
politiques qui chantent leurs chansons,
chansons qui plaisent et à tout le monde
dit voilà on va voter pour lui puisquil
nous promet des choses et puis après il
les fait pas. Et qu'est-ce qu'il fait
par la suite ? Et bien on le vote de
nouveau ou alors choisit un autre. Mais
c'est la base du capitalisme qui est le
problème puisqu'on vit dans cette
foi-là. Et aussi une chose à laquelle on
veut pas toucher, c'est le dogme de la
propriété. Moi je pense qu'il faut être
de la propriété, il faut avoir jusqu'à
certain niveau. Mais à partir du moment
où vous avez des milliards des milliards
de propriétés que vous pouvez vous
pouvez diriger des milliers de de
personnes, c'est plus acceptable. Vous
pouvez acheter les télévisions que vous
voulez, vous pouvez acheter les journaux
et et manipuler le peuple et cetera.
Vous voyez, c'est c'est la la déviance
totale à mon avis du capitalisme qui est
devenu un monstre un monstre pour les
démocraties mais et démocratie
pour lesquelles il en profite à fond.
Dans votre film, on voit la reproduction
d'un entretien entre Michel Sapin et
Yanis Varoufakis. Et un moment Michel
Sapin dit à Yanis Faroufakis, "La France
n'est plus ce qu'elle était."
Vous vous mon avis c'est assez triste
que le ministre de l'État français dise
une chose comme ça pour son pays. Il y a
quelqu'un d'autre qui connaît très peu.
En dehors de cela, je pense qu'il y
avait la France à l'époque et toujours
face en Allemagne, il y a une grande une
grande faiblesse une grande faiblesse.
Je pense que les présidents français ont
beaucoup. Ils ont pu mais ils n'ont pas
pu faire ce qu'ils voulaient. Alors je
sais actuellement parce que les discours
de du président Macron à la à la Soon
était un discours parfait. Mais j'espère
qu'il va pouvoir
la petite musique c'était quoi ?
Non, il disait non, il a proposé non il
a fait un discours il a fait un très bon
discours. Il proposait une Europe telle
que nous la rêvons telle que les
fondateurs l'ont l'ont rêvé aussi l'ont
l'ont fait. Euh les fondateurs de
l'Europe, ils voulaient quoi ?
Le
les fondateurs de l'Europe, ils
voulaient quoi ? C'était quoi les les
fondements de l'Europe ? Écoutez,
je crois hein, une Europe culturelle,
une Europe où le l'éducation est très
importante, une Europe où le social est
très important, une Europe où il y avait
le militaire aussi parce qu'à l'époque
il y avait le militaire, l'OTAN et
cetera et puis une époque aussi
d'économie. Aujourd'hui, ce n'est plus
que l'Europe de l'économie, ça veut dire
que l'Europe des banques, ça veut dire
l'Europe des actionnaires que comme je
disais avant choisissent le patron des
banques pour qu'il leur apporte de plus
en plus d'argent. Voilà. Et quand les
banques euh faillent, quand les banques
ne marchent plus, quand ils n'ont pas
réussi, qu'est-ce qu'il fait ? Et c'est
font payés par l'État, c'est-à-dire pas
nous. Voilà, c'est voilà les systèmes
qui qui qui é devenu un système
complètement hystérique et inacceptable.
Je vais je vais raconter une histoire à
notre communauté. En pleine crise
grecque, j'étais autour d'une table un
dîner très très important avec des gens
très très importants autour de la table.
Et en face de moi, j'avais une femme qui
gérait une des plus grosses fortunes
françaises
et qui euh euh mettait de l'argent sur
les obligations grecques. Et moi, je lui
posais la question, je lui disais "Mais
la Grèce vient de se faire dégrader, la
note de la Grèce se dégrade. Qu'est-ce
que tu utilises pour te couvrir ?" Vous
connaissez le principe. Vous prenez des
obligations d'un côté, vous prenez un un
pensement de l'autre. pour vous couvrir.
Vous savez ce qu'elle m'a répondu ? Mais
pourquoi tu veux que je me couvre ?
Sous-entendu,
il y aura toujours l'État qui paiera
derrière.
Exactement. C'est le cas des banques.
D'ailleurs, j'ai lu l'autre jour un un
article d'un d'un homme très sérieux qui
disait que d'ici 2 ans, on sent déjà une
nouvelle crise des banques qui va
arriver. Voilà, il va arriver et bah on
va payer encore. C'est cela. Alors c'est
ça qu'il faut sa Alors l'Europe si elle
était les plus unies s'il y avait un
parlement qui contrôlait beaucoup plus
les actions prises par les uns par les
autres contrôl aussi des barosa qui ne
prenaient pas des barosa dans le qui
empêchaient aussi que les que les genti
pas dans qu'il y avait des gens
intelligents et et et enfin sérieux à la
direction ça serait différent c'est à ça
qu'il faut que l'Europe devrait arriver
un jour
Macron Macron Emmanuel Macron c'est un
bon président c'est quelqu'un de bien
c'est Comment vous le percevez ?
Non, écoutez, quand il a fait un
discours comme celui d' Rome, moi je je
l'applaudis avec autant que je peux.
Quand il fait un discours sur l'Afrique,
le retour des certains œuvres d'art pour
l'Afrique et cetera, j'applaudis
beaucoup. Bon, maintenant, il faut avoir
les actions. Il est vrai aussi qu'un
président a des a des difficultés, il
faut changer des choses que les gens ne
veulent pas changer. Et c'est là où on
trouve son habileté, son intelligence
pour essayer de changer les choses parce
qu' il y a des choses qui doivent
changer. Mais mais là, alors il faut
attendre pour Macron, il faut attendre
encore 2 ans pour voir à la fin s'il a
réussi de faire ce qu'il a promis parce
que essentiellement c'est ça.
Vous votez en France ou vous votez en
Grèce ?
Non non, j'ai voté en France. J'avais en
Grèce, je suis parti, j'ai j'avais 20
ans en plus. Ça remonte à quand la
dernière fois que vous étiez en Grèce ?
Le
la dernière fois que vous étiez en
Grèce, c'était quand ?
Bah quand j'ai fait le film, j'ai fait
une grande partie du film en Grèce parce
que j'ai décidé de faire le film avec
qui qui parlent en anglais en grande
partie parce que en Europe on parle
l'anglais et puis en grec quand les
Grecs sont parmi eux. C'est ça. Donc
j'étais tourné sur place et j'ai tourné
d'ailleurs d'avant plus que je ne compté
parce que les acteurs grecs il jouent au
théâtre, il ne peut pas se déplacer à
l'Europe en France ou je pouris voulait
tourner ou à Luxembourg. Et ben j'ai
tourné beaucoup sur place, j'ai resté
plusieurs semaines à tourner plusieurs à
Athène. Oui.
Est-ce que vous avez vu un problème avec
les migrants en Grèce qui s'accumule sur
des points chauds sur Est-ce que est-ce
que vous sentez que le les flux
migratoires commencent à peser sur le
moral des Grecs ?
Mais ça c'est l'autre plie de la Grèce,
la plie la crise, la dette qui continue.
Vous avez oublié la Turquie.
Non et puis non la Turquie c'est un
vieux problème. Les immigrants, la
Turquie c'est un vieux problème. Le le
non l'immigrant les les les vous savez
les îles grecs ils sont à on peut aller
à la nage en Turquie. Elle dit Turquie,
on peut venir à la nage si on est bon
nageur. Alors ils viennent des milliers
d'immigrants. Il y a certaines îles qui
sont bourré bourré des évidemment c'est
un point énorme et c'est là encore une
fois l'Europe ferme les yeux. Il donne
un peu d'argent comme ça pour avoir des
tentes, un peu de nourriture et cetera,
mais c'est un point pour les Grecs.
Absolument, dont ils n'ont vraiment pas
besoin. Comment on fait pour régler ce
problème là ? Écoutez, vous demandez à
un cinéaste de trouver des solutions,
mais on paye des hommes politiques pour
trouver des solutions et les hommes
politiques sont payées et très bien payé
pour faire ces solutions. Un cinéaste
peut poser des questions éventuellement
et fait un beau spectacle ou que voilà
parce c'est essentiel aussi fait un film
où les gens ne s'emmerdent pas où on va
et pendant 2 he on va quelque chose qui
vous intéresse. Voilà ce qui m'intéresse
essentiellement et poser des questions.
les solutions.
Un cinéaste, un cinéaste, ça doit être
un objecteur de conscience. Ça doit être
quelqu'un qui doit montrer du doigt les
problèmes de la société sans en apporter
des solutions. Ça doit être ça doit être
comment un cinéaste ?
Et cinéaste doit être libre comme tout
citoyen et faire et dire ce qu'il a
envie de dire librement dans les
sociétés. Il n'est pas question de dire
vous faut que cess vous avez cessé là.
Il y a eu des régimes qui ont fait faire
qui ont dit au cinéast vous ferez c vous
ferez cela voilà des régimes
totalitaire. Non, c'est pas ça. Moi, je
dis pas que Sin doit être un homme libre
qui avec son talent ou son peu de talent
fasse ce qu'il a envie de faire comme
chaque citoyen
parce que c'est vrai qu'on a une
responsabilité puis qu'on fait on
s'adresse à des milliers de personnes à
des milliers de à des millions parfois
des personnes. Et ben c'est là faut pas
que quelqu'un nous dise il faut faire
ceci ou faire cela comme quelqu'un pas
dit il faut faire ces films faut faire
cela. Bon, il faut passer ce qu'elle a
dit la la Révolution française. Vous
savez, il y a la liberté.
Comment on fait pour garder sa liberté
quand on a besoin de financer un film
qui va, excusez-moi de parler comme ça,
qui va remuer la merde. Et ben
parce que vous remuez beaucoup la merde.
Je me bat, je me bat et j'ai réussi une
chance formidable. J'ai fait au début
des films qui ont marché très fort donc
on me fait confiance. et le film que
j'ai fait par la suite, ils ont été ils
ont marché
bien ou correctement en tout cas pour
que je puisse en faire d'autres. Voilà
la première avantage parce que si
j'avais pas si j'avais raté mes deux
trois premiers films, je serais disparu
comme beaucoup de collègues. Bon, il y a
ça et puis a aussi le fait qu'il faut se
battre. Il faut se battre pour certains
films comme celui-ci, bah essayer de
trouver de l'argent de partout et faire
des collaborateurs des acteurs par
exemple et ben on dit j'ai pas beaucoup
à vous payer et vous vous n'allez pas en
avion. en première classe, vous allez
avoir derrière, voilà et vous prenez un
taxi, vous n'aurez pas une voiture pour
vous. Donc on fait les choses dans
l'économie aussi. Il y a il y a il y a
beaucoup de choses et puis il y a
l'enthousiasme aussi des gens qui
s'intéressent à un projet comme c'était
pour comme c'est poussa lui aussi aussi
et on l'a fait finalement.
Qui a financé une lutte qui a financé
votre dernier film et combien ça a coûté
?
Qu'est-ce que
Qui a financé votre dernier film et
combien ça a coûté ? Écoutez, ça a été
très difficile jusqu'au moment où un où
un un distributeur WCH a dit moi je veux
distribu d'argent mais automatiquement a
déclenché les télévisions les
télévisions d'une certaine manière
télévision par exemple dit phase 2 il a
dit on vous donne un peu d'argent mais
pas pour autant qu'on donne le soir pour
pour passer le film à 8h à 9h du soir
vous allez passer plus tard
bon on l' accepté c'est déjà un canal
Plus comme j'ai une relation avec Canal
Plus, ils ont dit voilà on vous donne un
peu d'argent aussi. C'était comme ça. Ça
commençait comme ça un peu à peu. On a
réussi à faire de film, on a fait aussi
quelques dettes mais je pense on va les
épongers, on trouvera une solution.
C'est c'est euh si vous deviez regarder
votre public dans les yeux, est-ce que
vous lui diriez "Il faut voir ce film
pour comprendre les arcanes de du
pouvoir européen pour que vous soyez
endurci intellectuellement parlant ou
simplement allez voir mon spectacle ?
Vous allez apprendre deux trois trucs et
puis la vie continue.
Dites-leur pour pourquoi qu'est-ce qui
Non, moi je dirais non, je vous le
dirai, je veux pas le conseiller. Je
dirais voilà, vous allez voir un film un
film c'est pas un discours politique,
c'est pas un discours historique non
plus. Vous allez voir un film où on a
des passions, on aime, on rit par un
moment et on déteste par d'autres
moments. Et la colère c'est une bonne
chose. Je penseon peut faire des choses
avec la colère. Mais je peux vous
assurer que si vous faites un tout petit
peu attention, vous suivez ce qui se
passe, et ben vous allez pas vous
emmerder du tout du tout.
J'ai on on a plein de questions qui sont
en train d'arriver euh d'Internet. Euh
euh j'aimerais j'aimerais vous vous en
poser une.
L'austérité, ça a marché en Grèce. On
voit le taux taux de chômage. Je me fais
l'avocat du diable, me regardez pas
comme ça.
L'austérité, ça a fonctionné. Regardez,
un taux de chômage qui était au plus
fort de la crise de 28 % qui est passé
près des 17 % 16,9 % 2000 2009 2019
pardon. Euh la Grèce est à 2,5 % de
croissance.
Oui,
ça s'est fait au détriment de du peuple
grec, du de la qualité de vie des Grecs.
Mais ça a fonctionné.
Oui.
Les Grecs ont été des bons esclaves des
banques, non ?
Oui, mais il y a Grèce en ce moment,
c'était dans le point il y a quelques
temps, il y a 35 % de Grec pauvre et sur
trois salaires 1 est de 3017.
Voilà et que les suicides commencent à
être 40 % par rapport plus de 40 % comme
par rapport avant et que la pauvreté
veut dire les autres enfin c'est qu'ils
ne sont pas complètement pour à 35 % ils
sont pas très riches non plus. Ils sont
aussi un peu moins pauvres que les
autres. C'est-à-dire que ça va durer
encore au moins 10 ans. Certains disent
même 15 ans s'il y a une solution n'est
pas prise pour changer la situation
cette situation de de d'ostérité qui
continue d'ailleurs. L'austérité elle
s'est pas cessée.
Vous avez regardé les images de 20112 de
ce qui s'est passait en Grèce.
Vous ne montrez pas dans votre film des
violences du peuple contre
l'institution, contre le Parlement grec.
La plastic Sintagma qui était en feu
pratiquement tous les jours, tous les
weekends avec un déploiement de force de
l'ordre de qualité militaire. Nous
français avec les gilets jaunes, on voit
ce que ça fait dans nos rues. Mais en
Grèce, ça c'est ça c'est c'est arrivé
beaucoup plus tôt. On a vu en Grèce les
Voltigeurs, les motards Voltigeers
revenir faire leur petite ratonnade dans
les rues avec les les manifestants.
Comment vous percevez cette violence du
peuple ?
Les black block s'attaquent à certaines
institutions bancaires. Le peuple
commence à faire des cocktails molotof
et et à cartonner la police. Qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de cette violence ?
Est-ce que c'est une violence légitime ?
Est-ce que ça sert le peuple ? Est-ce
que c'est intéressant ? Pourquoi vous
vous l'avez pas mis en image ? Euh ma
question un peu fouillie mais je vous
laisse comme ça.
Là, écoutez, c'est une question
difficile parce que je pense que les
manifestations sont importantes,
essentielles pour le peuple. Il y en a
eu énormément à Grèce et puis on passait
par moment aux violences. C'est le
désespoir. Je pense que la violence
physique, la destruction et cetera joue
un rôle contraire de ce qu'on veut
jouer. C'est-à-dire parce que ça
renforce l'adversaire la violence. Quand
on casse à Paris, comme on a fait
beaucoup, on affaibli beaucoup les verts
par exemple, les jaunes, je veux dire.
Donc c'est ça la violence. Je ne crois
pas à la violence parce que ça produit
un effet contraire. Par contre, je pense
que aux grandes manifestations sont
essentielles de descendre pas des
milliers comme ils les font les
Algériens aujourd'hui, comme ils ont
fait comme ils ont fait les Chiliens,
comme ils ont fait à Beou aussi en
évitant la violence parce que ça devient
le le la possibilité de le combattre de
l'adversaire. Voilà. Alors, à ce qui
concerne la Grèce, il y a eu des énormes
violences, il y a eu des gonommes
manifestations qui n'ont abouti à rien
malheureusement. C'est-à-dire aucun ACD,
ni les gouvernements grecs de l'époque
qui étaient la droite et la gauche
ensemble d'ailleurs ils étaient ils ont
fait une coalition à un moment donné
ni l'Europe qui a vu ce peuple sortir
dans la rue et qui n'ont s'en fichant
complètement. Donc aujourd'hui le peuple
ne le fait plus parce que parce qu'il ne
croit plus à ça. C'estàd il est
désespéré et en même temps que la vie
cette manifestation ne aboutisse à rien.
J'en montre dans les films des manifest
manifestations quand il y a des
élections. Il y a les élections donc il
y a un espoir qu'un nouveau parti
arrivera au pouvoir et il va pouvoir
changer des choses. Et voilà, il y a eu
Siiza est arrivé au pouvoir et
malheureusement n'a pas changé beaucoup
de choses ou très peu et que l'Europe
mais là il y a une logique de l'Europe
de ne pas aider un parti de gauche
radical parce que s'il lui faisait un
cadeau ça ça encouragerait d'autres
partis de gauche comme en France comme
en Espagne et ailleurs. Donc il était
pas question. L'autre position de
l'Europe c'était dépunir la Grèce comme
je l'ai dit. Et l'autre position, c'est
d'en faire un exemple d'en faire un
exemple que les autres ne font pas des
des
Ça c'est votre interprétation votre
C'est mon interprétation. Absolum, c'est
mon interprétation. Et et l'autre était
aussi c'est que les Europ, c'est aussi
mon interprétation, les Européens,
beaucoup d'Européens notamment les
Allemands, méprisaient les Grecs,
méprisez les Grecs parce que pendant des
années, les gouvernements précédents
gauche et droite avaient envoyé des
fausses chiffres à l'Europe en disant
voilà ça va mieux et cetera et et aussi
parce que il pouvait aussi dans certains
cas payer des ministres grecs pour
vendre des produits européens allemands
ou même français. Il a même des
ministres qui ont été en prison. Donc
tout cela faisait que la Grèce était un
pays un tout petit peu qu'on respectait
pas beaucoup. Alors le respect pouvait
venir quand la gauche est arrivé au
pouvoir. Le grand espoir pour tout le
monde, pas pour les Européens
naturellement. Et ça n'a pas marché là
non plus malheureusement.
Alors les manifestations, il faut que ça
prenne quelle tournure ? C'est une
petite marge dans la rue comme ça. C'est
c'est quoi ? C'est une grve de la fin
généralisée, c'est on va pas travailler.
C'estàd que on le manifestation, elle
est pas travaillé pendant ou des jours.
Ça ça c'est on montre quand même que que
le peuple réagit puisqu'il y a pas
d'autres moyens de des de réagir.
Grève générale,
pourquoi pas ? Pourquoi pas ? J'ai pas
encore une fois j'ai pas des des des
conseils à donner ni à dire il faut
faire ceci ou faut faire cela. Mais je
prends les Chiliens que je connais bien,
je les ai appelé parce j'avais des amis
quand il m'a dit ça va pas être ça va
pas être violent du tout, on va
manifester. Et c'est la le le
gouvernement qui était violent, il a il
a fait sortir l'armée comme Pinoché,
vous comprenez ? Et finalement, ils
avaient tellement raison puisque le le
euh président, il a fait marche arrière.
Alors, on va voir s'il va changer
beaucoup de choses par la suite. Mais
mais je pense que quand le peuple il est
coinsail complètement et ben qu'est-ce
qu'il voulait faire d'autre que
descendre dans la rue pour se pour se
pour se prononcer pour dire voilà on
veut autre chose que ce que vous nous
proposez.
Les gilets jaunes, vous en pensez quoi ?
Non, je trouve que c'est un mouvement
très intéressant, hein. C'est un
mouvement très qui a été salopé
malheureusement par
par S plutôt par les par les types les
casseurs qui sont venus et qui ont fait
beaucoup beaucoup de mal parce que le
bons les bonnes choses que proposaient
euh les gilets jaunes ont été absolument
ont été euh comme quoi c'était quoi les
bonnes choses que les gilets jaunes
proposaient ?
Écoutez-nous, on veut changer ceci, on
veut changer cela. Il y avait aussi des
des choses un peu ahurantes quand
quelqu'un disait il faut changer
président de la République. Bon, ça
change pas comme ça un président de la
République. C'est c'est normal aussi
parce que il y a une sorte de désespoir
quelque part qui s'exprimait en tout cas
et ça c'est bien
que le désespoir s'exprime
bien sûr
quand quand le le président qualifie les
les certaines personnes de gens de rien
de de notre précédent président appelé
ça les send
mais les présidents disent aussi des
choses qu'il devraient pas dire comme il
y a un autre président qui a dit parlant
des parlant des arabes il a dit les
odeurs et les et les bruit vous
comprenez
oui
Ça c'est inacceptable. Vraiment, il faut
choisir bien quand même la langue. La
langue française a plein plein de bons
mots et des bonnes phrases pour
s'exprimer sans aller sans aller à ces
extraits là, ces extrêmes là. Voilà. Et
puis ça n'est pas les
les black block. Les black block pour
vous c'est une plie. C'est quoi ? C'est
contre contreproductif à ce point-là.
C'est les plaisirs personnels. Ils
expriment leur plaisir personnel.
Ils expriment une une violence qu'on
imposé. C'estàd c'est contre la société
quand même en tout cas c'est pourquoi on
casse. Ça veut dire quoi ? Quelle est la
signification de casser ? Ça produit le
contraire parce que ça renforce la
police, ça renforce l'extrême droite, ça
renforce les peines, ça renforce tout le
temps avec la casse. C'est ça qui
produisent essentiellement rien d'autre.
Donc je pense qu'à la fin du compte ce
qui c'est à quoi ils aspirent c'est de
se faire du plaisir pendant qu'on casse.
Voilà.
Le Brexit vous en pensez quoi ?
Le
Brexit. Le Brexit, vous savez les
anglais nous ont fait suer pendant des
années hein de toute façon. Alors bon
là, il continue, on va voir qu'est-ce
qui va sortir. Mais c'est vrai que c'est
malheureux que quelqu'un s'en arrive
parce qu'on sait pas ce que peut devenir
la l'Angleterre une fois en dehors. On a
en CD avec Luxembourg
paradis fiscal mais vous rendez compte
si l'Angleterre devient l'utre paradis
fiscal.
Quand à l'époque de la crise grecque,
les Allemands voulaient faire sortir la
Grèce.
Euh et vous dites que Emmanuel Macron a
fait tout son possible pour préserver la
Grèce au sein de l'Europe. Non, Macron,
il a beaucoup aidé, poussé euh euh
Hollande, le président Hollande, de le
faire. Et c'est vrai que finalement le
président Hollande l'a fait et c'est
grâce au président Hollande qui a
convaincu aussi madame Merkel que la
Grèce n'est pas sortie de la de de de
l'euro parce que le ministre allemand le
voulait absolument et derrière lui il
avait toute l'Allemagne il y a au moins
70 % des personnes qui suivent Chbel
parce c'est quelqu'un d'être très aimé
en Allemagne et tout le monde croit à
lui.
quand la il y a il y a une question
d'Internet euh qui n'est pas une
question
qu' il y a Choubi qui nous dit "Pourquoi
il met l'accent sur les casseurs et pas
sur les abus de la police par exemple ?
Est-ce que vous avez suivi les violences
policières que la la
J'ai suivi ? Alors là, on rentre dans un
dans un encore dans on va me donner une
que je donne une opinion. C'est un
problème très complexe parce que si vous
avez les casseurs, si vous avez, je vais
pas justifier les policiers mais si vous
avez cette violence là, les policiers
réagissent violemment et de l'autre côté
la violence augmente et sa violence fait
boule de neige. sais pas où on va et
c'est vrai que les policiers aussi je
mets parfois met à la place je vais
faire beaucoup d'ennemis làin mais tant
pis mais je baise la place de d'un
policier qui a 20 25 ans 30 ans et que
tous les jours il va pendant 4 he se
mettre tout ce machin là sur la tête et
il va poursuivre des gens en courant ou
essayer de taper sur des gens qui
veulent taper aussi et et cetera ça au
bout d'un moment je pense ça doit
arriver à des excès extrêmes. Voilà.
Alors, je vais pas les justifier, je
vais justifier personne, mais il faut
essayer de comprendre et que ces
manifestations doivent se passer dans le
calme. C'est la seule façon d'ailleurs
que ça soit des manifestations qui
apportent quelque chose. Dès qu'on passe
à la violence ou aux insultes comme on
le fait souvent, là c'est le pire des
choses. Je répété plusieurs fois, c'est
l'autre côté qui bénéficie. La violence
et la force des faibles et commence où
s'arrête les connaissances c'est notre
problème.
Non, la violence c'est nécessaire
parfois si vous êtes occupé si par un
ennemi, si le pays est occupé s'il y a
des choses qu'il veut pas accepter et
ben vous interz
la violence quelqu'un qui bat sa femme
et ben vous intervenez parfois même
violemment s'il est faux. Mais mais la
violence ça n'est pas la première chose
à à accepter.
On va revenir sur d'autres films. Est-ce
que vous avez des films à conseiller ?
Quels sont pour vous trois films à
conseiller ?
Le mien d'abord actuellement le mien
d'abord actuellement.
Bah il y a on va voir le film le
j'accuse des films de Polinski. C'est
sûrement un film très intéressant. C'est
un grand metteur en scène qui fait des
beaux films.
Vous parlez de Polanski euh on l'accuse
souvent d'être un gros pédophile.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette
histoire là ? On accuse souvent Polonsk
d'être un gros pédophile.
Oui, mais je pense que grand c'est c'est
vraiment pas réfléchi tout ça. Pouraski
a fait une grave faute il y a plus de 40
ans et depuis il a monté une vie
exemplaire. Il a fait des films, une
famille, des enfants. Il est c'est le
moment de dire voilà pardon par sans
pardon. Je dis pas qu'il faut oublier
mais il faut pardonner par sans pardon
la société n'existe pas. C'est la guerre
civile permanente donc il faut arrêter
avec. Il y a d'autres types qui font des
choses aujourd'hui qui malgré la
mauvaise exemple continue à le faire
aujourd'hui. C'estàdire
vous en avez vu beaucoup dans le cinéma
des gens comme ça
le
Vous en avez vu beaucoup des gens comme
ça dans le cinéma ? Non, j'en ai pas vu
beaucoup mais enfin moi je vais pas dire
un tel tel a fait ceci. Non, je pense
que le cinéma américain il est il est
différent. Euh je et le pouvoir des des
producteurs là-bas de maturen est
différent. En France c'est différent les
choses parce que il y a quand même une
autre logique mais ça arrive aussi ça
peut arriver. Donc il faut pour revenir
à Polaski, il faut laisser tranquille
maintenant. Et puis il arrive à un âge
où il a raison de de pardon surtout je
l'assiste. Sans pardon une société
n'existe pas.
Deux autres films à regarder de films à
regarder. Film de Bokio qui est un très
beau film aussi sur la mafia. Bo, c'est
bon mur en scène. Euh, il y a le film
aussi de Céline Chama qui est un très
beau film.
Il y a des films, il y a plein de films.
Il y a la cinématique, il y a plein de
films. À ce moment, il y a des il y a
une série de de de de film d'abord, il y
a une exposition sur les vampires. Il y
a une série de films sur les vampires
qui sont très entre autres entre autres.
Est-ce que vous avez vu V pour vent
d'état ?
Non, j'ai pas vu encore.
Pas vu encore. Euh est-ce que vous avez
des livres à conseiller à notre
communauté ? Trois livres.
Écoutez par du du livre de des Varou
Faakis
qui si on s'intéresse à l'économie bah
là on apprend beaucoup de choses. Il a
été même classé parmi les 100 meilleurs
livres écrits sur l'économie depuis
toujours. Il a été aussi classé parmi
les par un autre journal anglais parmi
les 100 meilleurs livres du 21e siècle.
Toute toute discipline euh incluse.
Qu'est-ce que je lis d'autre ?
J'ai pas beaucoup de choses
dernièrement.
Est-ce que vous avez
Il faut relire il faut relire il faut
relire Victor Hugo de temps en temps. Il
faut revenir aussi peut-être sur Balzac
les anciens parce qu'il parle de notre
société c'est des livres profondément
politiques s'intéressent à voilà. Euh
est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de l'exception culturelle
française avec le cinéma ? Il
était social l'exception culturelle.
Pourquoi ? Parce que paro, on revient
encore au président, il voulait quoi ?
Il voulait considérer les œuvres de
l'esprit, c'est-à-dire les le cinéma,
les livres et tout, la musique et tout
cela comme des produits comme tous les
autres produits plutôt, c'est-à-dire
pouvoir vendre et acheter sans pouvoir
avoir une aide particulière ou une vie
particulière à à ces produits de
l'esprit. C'est-à-dire quand Jacques
Lang par exemple a décidé que le prix de
livre serait partout le même. Voilà.
Mais euh Baros voulait annuler ça,
voilà. Et d'autres plein d'autres aides
comme cela. C'est ça l'exception
culturelle. Donc ça, il faut continuer.
C'est pas c'était une idée de
l'exception culturelle essentielle pour
protéger la culture nationale, pas que
la française d'ailleurs, tous les autres
cultures européennes.
Vous pensez que l'Europe, la France va
où pour les trois prochaines années ?
Vous avez un sentiment positif face à
l'avenir ? Vous êtes confiant ou est-ce
que vous redoutez l'avenir pour vos
enfants, vos petits-enfants ?
Non, c'est c'est c'est l'avenir était
n'est pas n'est pas rose hein, que ça
soit sur le plan de du climat, ça sur le
plan économique. C'est pour ça que je
crois que que l'Europe doit changer
parce que l'Europe c'est le fait d'être
tous ensemble, on peut affronter ces
problèmes là d'une manière beaucoup plus
forte que si on se laisse comme ça, on
se sépare, on se fait bouffer par les
uns les autres très facilement.
Vous croyez encore à l'Europe ?
À l'Europe ? Ah oui, je crois
absolument. Je crois c'est une
nécessité. Et puis il y a des Écoutez,
il y avait pas d'av d'aviation
d'industrie d'avion en Europe. Il y
avait la française et puis un peu ici et
là et puis finalement on a réussi, on a
voulu à se mettre tous ensemble pour
construire les avions. Et bon, ils ont
gagné les Américains, n'est-ce pas ? et
les avions européens aujourd'hui
l'industrie d'aviation européenne même
si pour l'environnement n'est pas
toujours très positive bon elle marche
bien mais je pense chaque fois que les
Européens se réunis pour trouver une
solution et ben ça a bien marché donc je
pense que une des raisons deè et c'est
pas la moindre d'être européen de croire
à l'Europe.
On a on a une question d'internet qui
nous dit "Pour être pardonné, il faut
avoir été jugé en référence à l'affaire
Polanski. Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
?"
Avoir été jugé qui ?
Pour être pardonné, il faut avoir été
jugé
en référence à Polonski.
Oui, je sais ça, je sais. Mais alors, il
faut connaître aussi la justice
américaine parce qu'il y a des juges qui
sont élus et quand ils sont élus, ils y
vont à fond pour être élus à la
prochaine élection. Donc je ne vais pas
entrer dans cette ce que j'ai dit il
faut pardonner
le temps peut juger mais celle qui avait
à juger pour l'inscrit surtout puisqu'il
s'est tradé de nouveau c'est la sa
victime mais elle elle a pardonné et
c'est notre tour de pardonner.
Une autre question de de Youfolk. Est-ce
que vous avez un ami imaginaire qui
serait le seul vrai juge ? Alors ici on
dit ami imaginaire pour la religion.
Est-ce que vous croyez en Dieu ?
Non non, je suis très fâché avec lui
depuis très longtemps parce que j'ai vu
à ma jeunesse des malheurs épouvantables
et je demande pourquoi. Et quand je fais
un film
qu'on m'amène où on parle un tout petit
peu de camp de concentration, on se
demande comment Dieu a laissé faire ça.
Comment Dieu laisse faire oui bah
l'explication comment Dieu laisse faire
les nazis, comment dire cette violence
extrêmement il peut être très bien
d'après ce qu'on nous dit. Vous pouvez
dire stop et ça serait bien. Soyez
gentil et tout le monde serait gentil.
On le fait pas.
La religion c'est pas un petit peu un
spectacle qu'on a créé pour mener les
peuples ?
Non. La religion à mon avis la religion
Moïse tout ça, ils ont créé des règles.
Ils ont prévu des règles pour
pacifier la société pour que ce ne soit
pas le jungle. Voilà. Mais finalement
ces règlesl ont été après utilisées
d'une autre manière pour prendre du
pouvoir pour faire le contraire de très
souvent de ce que les règles euh les
lois comme les euh disent absolument
malheureusement qui des un autre type de
pouvoir. La religion est devenue partout
un autre type de pouvoir sans parler de
ceux qui ont vraiment partent dans
l'excès complètement et que tout ce qui
les intéresse personnellement le mettre
sur le dos de la religion.
Autre question internet. Est-ce que vous
avez déjà participé à des manifestations
? Euh alors le notre auditeur ajoute
parce que j'ai l'impression qu'il ne
sait pas comment ça se passe avec les
flics.
Manifestation, j'étais j'étais souvent
des manifestations, j'en ai filmé
beaucoup d'ailleurs. J'ai toute une
collection des films, des manifestations
des manifestants que j'ai je filmais.
Oui, absolument. J'ai pas ça.
Autre question d'internet. Quel regard
porte-t-il sur le cinéma de son fils
Romain Gavras ?
Mon fils a eu l'intelligence de faire un
cinéma qui ne ressemble pas du tout au
mien et je trouve que c'est bravo.
Voilà.
Quel euh est-ce que vous avez une
citation personnelle ? Question
d'internet.
Une citation personnelle
si il y en a une qui me plaît beaucoup
mais je sais pas si on peut la on peut
on peut la la l'appliquer facilement.
qui dit que
euh
je n'ai pas peur, je ne veux rien,
je suis libre.
Ça vous c'est c'est important pour vous
la liberté ? Non,
essentiel essentiel surtout que j'ai
vécu le contraire quand j'étais jeune.
Pour la liberté euh il faut toujours se
battre.
Oui, absolument. Mais la liberté, c'est
complexe. La liberté qu' est la liberté
de quelqu'un
qui gagne le SMIG et quelqu'un qui gagne
5000 € par mois.
Quelle est la liberté ? Où est la
liberté ? Donc c'est pour ça que la
société doit s'arranger pour trouver un
meilleur équilibre là-dedans. Il est
possible mon avis, il est possible.
Question question d'Internet. La
polémique sur le voile en France sert à
quoi selon lui ?
La quoi là ? La polémique sur le voile,
voile.
J'ai trou une absurdité totale. C'est
l'absurdité totale parce que
bah ça conduit à des extrêmes, ça
conduit à haï l'autre et le juger
contrairement à ce qu'il est l'autre et
aussi conduit à con à à juger toute une
communauté
qui est la communauté arabe, qui est la
communauté musulmane en France qui est
énorme qui tous ne portent pas les
voiles et tous ne sont pas djihadistes
mais on donne l'impression qu'ils sont
tous responsables dans tout cela et ça
c'est lament able
question d'internet est-ce que vous avez
un avis sur l'anarchisme ?
L'anarchisme, j'ai connu des anarchismes
qui m'ise beaucoup parce que parce que
chacun c'est chacun pour soi fait ce
qu'il veut et cetera. Je pense pas je ne
pense pas que un un anarchisme les
anarchistes puissent puissent créer une
société juste et libre. C'est
impossible.
D'ailleurs, on peut être lychiste mais
enfin on vit quand même dans cette
société démocratique
que nous avons créé.
Alors autre question d'internet, est-ce
que vous connaissez la collapsologie
là ?
La collapsologie
non
la science de l'étude de l'effondrement.
L'effondrement économique,
l'effondrement clim climatique.
Non ben je vais me renseigner de de ce
soir de demain matin. Oui.
Non, c'est pas mal. Ouais. Euh est-ce
que vous avez trois lits ? Alors les
livres, on les a déjà fait. Euh
euh on va juste attendre que notre
communauté nous fasse remonter deux
trois autres questions. Moi je vais vous
poser une question qu'on pose à tout le
monde. C'est c'est pas une question,
c'est laisser un conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
Que le
laisser un conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
Non, j'ai pas de conseils.
Pourquoi
j'ai pas de conseils ? Parce que chacun
doit trouver son sa voix tout seul.
Il y a qu'une chose qu'on peut dire
éventuellement. Faites des études, c'est
essentiel. faites des études parce que
ça vous ouvre un chemin où on peut
choisir soi-même
sans attendre que les autres choisissent
pour vous qui vous donne des conseils.
Question d'internet si on vous donne
trois bulletins de vote Mélenchon Macron
et Le Penisseriez
vous choisisseriez le quel butin de vol
que presque automatiquement par la
peine. Je pense que Mélenchon il a
beaucoup déçu.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de de
Christine Lagarde ?
Christine Lagarde Christine Lagarde est
elle est semble elle est positive dans
le film pour deux raisons parce que
d'abord elle a dit cette dette est
impossible à payer pendant que tous les
autres chantaient il faut la payer il
faut la payer et elle a fini par dire
aussi que il faut des adultes dans cet
dans ce lie titre du film c'estàd vou
dire que tout ce que vous racontez c'est
pas juste donc c'est formidable il a
fait une autre chose aussi que vous
connaissez c'est pas très connu enfin
c'est oublié quand il était ministre des
finances en France et a envoyé au
gouvernement grec qui a été à cette
époque était des socialistes pas dans la
crise, il liste avec 2100 ou 200 je
crois fortune grecque qui était en
Suisse. Ça s'est fait jamais ces
choses-là. Et a fait et le ministre
grec, il a pris un socialiste, il a
chassé les noms qui étaient proches de
lui et il a envoyé un autre ministre.
L'autre ministre a dit je l'ai perdu.
Donc il y a plus de de de liste.
Jusqu'au jour, un journaliste a publié
dans ce journal cette liste et les
procureur général d'Athè lui a fait un
procès pour avoir divulgué des secrets
d'état. Et heureusement, les
journalistes du monde entier ont fait
une pétition et la la la
le procès n'a jamais eu lieu. Non, je
veux dire que donc Christine Lagarde a
fait une chose que ne s'est fait pas
souvent hein, qui un tas en voit envoyé
une liste de ces types à un autre état.
Donc et là une certaine sympathie pour
moi pour je pense pas d'ailleurs que ce
soit un ange parce que quand on dirige
des sociétés enfin des entreprises aussi
énormes, il doivent avoir des moments de
très violentes.
Euh est-ce que vous pensez que la
presse, les journalistes ont un sont
responsables de la situation
au moment de la crise greque ? Est-ce
que vous vous trouvez que les
journalistes ont fait leur devoirs, ont
fait leur boulot d'information sur la
réalité de la la crise grecque ? J'ai
pas jouer les journalistes parce qu'il y
a pas les journalistes, il y a des
journalistes et des chaînes et des
journaux. Donc on va pas entrer dans ça,
c'est une énorme. Mais j'ai je
m'aperçois que par exemple certains
personnages qui font des discours
journalistes qui font discours qui
mettent le feu, qui risquent de mettre
le feu, ils sont repris, ils sont
publiés encore et encore, ils sont même
pris dans certaines chaînes, voilà et
répéter. Donc ça à mon avis c'est un peu
euh c'est inacceptable mais c'est pas
les journalistes n'est-ce pas ?
Alors question d'internet. Que pense
monsieur Costa Gavras du film Landromat
sur l'affaire des Panama Peper et de de
Sa Soderberg du réalisateur Soderberg.
Je connais bien,
j'ai bien ce qu'il fait. J'ai pas vu son
dernier film mais mais
j'ai envie de les voir. J'ai entendu
toutes sortes de des des des réactions
et des des et des critiques.
Est-ce que vous avez vu le film Joker ?
Non, pas encore.
Est-ce que vous allez le voir ?
Sûrement. Oui. Oui. C'est un phénomène
énorme et cetera et il a eu un prix à
venir. C'est sûrement un film important.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du
téléchargement sur internet ?
Téléchargement sur internet ?
Si moi je pompe votre film.
Non, je pense que c'est c'est très
négatif. C'est c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui on peut avoir les films pour
très peu d'argent, aller en salle ou
parce que avoir un abonnement et cetera,
on peut voir tant de film et l'internet
d'abord il les voit de très mauvaise
condition parce que c'est des copies
pouvent souvent.
Ça dépend si vous allez sur le le
réseaux russes, c'est très très bonne
qualité. Bah, c'est pas un conseil à
donner à tout le monde quand même.
Et l'industrie du film se se porte très
bien.
Non, mais il y a un autre phénomène.
Vous n'allez pas prendre une baguette
sans la payer. Vous n'allez pas prendre
je sais pas quoi sans le payer. Donc, il
faut un peu d'argent pour faire des
films. On a parlé de l'argent, des
difficultés qu'on a. Si tout le monde se
met à internet et voir les films ou le
maître comme arrivé pour certains de mes
films, quelqu'un, j'ai appris un jour
que quelqu'un du Maroc, je sais pas
pourquoi, il a mis Z. Donc tout le monde
peut l'avoir gratuitement mais si on n
pas de retour un peu d'argent quand les
films passent et deviennent public on fa
appuer les films. C'est un business a
changé. Regardez nous on fonctionne que
sur des dons. On met nos productions
gratuitement sur internet et les gens
nous donnent la pièce.
Et ben nous on peut pas fonctionner
faire des films sur les dons parce que
d'abord c'est un per cher et que les
gens au bout d'un moment ils se
fatiguent. Donc il faut qu'il a retour.
Il y a cette relation là et puis je
pense qu'on ne respecte pas les œuvres
si on paye pas comme ça. Dit voilà je
vous paye 5 € 10 € et puis je vais voir
ce que vous avez fait. C'est un minimum
à mon avis.
Est-ce que vous pensez que l'État doit
mettre ses
doit encore plus gérer la production
cinématographique en finançant des films
? L'État ne finance pas les films. C'est
une c'est un vieux truc de la droite et
de l'extrême droite. L'État ne finance
pas les films. En France, on a trouvé un
système depuis de Gaulle pour que la
France a un cinéma national. On a trouvé
des règles au fur et à mesure. C'est
vrai qu'il y a un financement qui est
minime, c'est pas beaucoup d'argent
mais il y a des règles qui ont été
établies depuis le début. Je vous donne
un exemple que vous connaissez même pas.
Entre l'exemple, remettez votre micro
juste un peu plus haut. Votre micro.
Ah oui,
là ça va là.
Jeit donc
non,
regardez en France
le samedi soir dans les grandes chaînes,
il y a pas de film. Pourquoi ? Parce que
pour que les gens puent sortir, aller au
cinéma, au théâtre et cetera. Sinon, on
aurait tous les gros gros succès le
samedi soir, ils rester tous à la
maison. Et ça, ça a été décidé par
l'État. C'est l'aide, c'est ça l'aide,
l'aide de l'État. et des fin des
cinéastes qui ont demandé de faire ça et
la télévision qui l'ont accepté. Une
autre chose,
il y a pas de publicité de des des des
films au cinéma au télévision. Pourquoi
? Parce que les gros le gros ris du
cinéma allait faire de la publicité et
les autres films n'auraient pas de
spectateurs. Donc il y a une série de ce
type d'arrangement avec l'État et avec
ceux qui pouvaient détruire le cinéma.
qui fait que le cinéma français continue
à exister et qui il a quelques 300000
personnes qui travaillent pour le cinéma
dans son ensemble et que c'est une
partie de l'économie du du pays et qui a
une grande liberté aussi et une grande
diversité.
Il y a une réflexion de de Bruni. 10 €
quand on a à peine de quoi manger, ça
fait quand même cher. Non
non, vous pouvez vous abonner avec je
crois que c'est 25 ou 30 € et pouvez
autant voir autant de films que vous
voulez
dans les grandes salles dans le grand
écran et c'est unique au monde en
France.
Dernière question parce qu'on va pas
pouvoir passer à toutes. Que
pensent-t-il de la polarisation de la
pensée médiatique ?
De la pensée médiatique genre BFM, LCI
et cetera. Et moi, je rajouterai comment
on fait pour ne pas se radicaliser
politiquement parlant ? Comment on fait
pour ne pas se fanatiser politiquement
parlant ?
Réfléchir. On a une chose que la nature
nous a donné, réfléchir et avoir de
l'éducation. Moi, j'ai appris à ne pas
être radical, à ne pas être violent
politiquement quand je fréquentais des
gens comme je disais avant mon signoré
Chris Marquer et quelques autres parce
qu'il parlait calmement des problèmes
politiques. Il ne disait pas celui-là
qui va nous sauver, alors il faut aller
derrière lui quoi qu'il fasse que les
autres ils sont tous des salons. Non,
ils ont tous des idées différentes mais
il faut voir qui correspond le mieux à
notre sensibilité et l'accepter ou pas.
Ça n'est pas avec la violence et surtout
pas avec les la la fermeture de l'esprit
complètement. qu'on qu' qu'on peut qu'on
peut aller de l'avant et peu comprendre.
Alors encore une dernière petite
question parce qu'ils sont nombreux.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de Netflix ?
Du
Netflix.
Netflix. Ah lesplique, c'est c'est un
gros problème. C'est un gros problème
avec les choses positives et les choses
négatives. Le positif c'est que avec
très peu d'argent 10 € ou je sais pas
combien on peut s'abonner voir beaucoup
de films et beaucoup de gens qui
n'avaient pas accès au films vivent dans
des petits villages pas des sales ou
ailleurs je sais pas où. Donc ils
peuvent choisir et voir des films. Ça
c'est très important et très positif.
Mais le flix il prend un film il le met
dans la boîte et on entend plus parler.
C'estàd on sait pas que des gens par
exemple ont vu ce film du tout. On peut
pasir les form. Il y a un autre système
en France et dans beaucoup d'autres
pays, c'est les droits d'auteur.
C'està-dire que quand le film est vu par
quelqu'un, il y a un retour qu'on
appelle les droits d'auteur qui sont pas
seulement pour les aussi pour les
producteurs et cetera et qui permettent
de faire d'autres films. Le flix ne fait
pas ça. En plus si les flix grossit de
plus en plus, il va s'imposer
complètement. Il va dire "Vous ferez ce
film. Ce film je le paye. Ce film je le
paye pas. Ou alors vous changerez dans
ce film ceci et cela. C'est ça. C'est ça
de problème Netflix. Ils sont prêt à ils
sont prêts à payer centaines de millions
pour avoir Scot 16 ce film 120 140 plus
millions pour le pour leur publicité
pour dire mais il y a pas que ça dans le
cinéma. Il y a pas un scotch il va des
milliers des centaines d'autres films
qui ne se produisent pas
automatiquement.
Donc il faut qu'il change. Il n'est pas
question de les éradiquer, de les
sortir. Il est question de dire il faut
vous adapter à notre façon de vivre, à
notre démocratie à nous, pas à vos
intérêts à vous qui finalement ne sont
quoi parce que je vois pas que Netflix
pour prolonger un tout petit peu mon
idée et un projet culturel, il a un
projet de gagner de plus en plus de
l'argent pour ces actionnaires.
Question encore, il y en a tellement des
questions. Peut-on dire qu'Alexis Cypra
c'est un traître à la nation car il a
transformé le nom du peuple en oui à la
suite du référendum de juillet 2015
n'aurait-il pas dû démissionner ?
Écoutez, là-dessus, le film est très
clair, surtout la fin du film de mon
film.
Il faut pas dire la fin du film. On la
connaî la fin, non ?
Oui, je vais pas la dire mais enfin mais
mais c'est vrai que que après avoir
promis ce qu'il a promis, il a accepté
le contraire. Mais l'avantage qu'il a
CPRAS d'une certaine manière, c'est
qu'près avoir promis cela. Il va au
parlement grec, il dit "Voilà, j'ai
promis cela, qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez ?" On les vote à 73 % énorme tôt.
Et ensuite, qu'est-ce qu'il fait ? Il va
il fait une élection nationale et il la
gagne. Donc le peuple l'accepte de
nouveau. Mais quelle est la conclusion
de tout cela ? Éthiquement ça ne marche
pas. Éthiquement il n'est pas éthique.
Légal, il est légal mais pour moi, il
n'est pas éthique. Et et une une un
homme politique ou un système politique
sans éthique, ça n'est plus la
démocratie. C'est vraiment n'importe
quoi.
Costa Gavras, merci.
Merci à vous.
C'est coupé.
Et ben voilà.
[Musique]